todos en el reino están muy
impresionados con tu capacidad de ayudar
en la planeación del banquete en su
honor todos excepto uno que es esta
persona que está aquí este es regla y él
es el mejor consejero del rey y además
es el mayor planeador de las fiestas del
reino y él se siente algo amenazado por
tu habilidad para resolver estos
problemas sin solución o al menos sin
solución desde su punto de vista así que
él se acerca al rey y entonces le dice
rey el problema de los pastelillos fue
un problema sencillo que te has les
cuentas el problema de las papas fritas
pues estoy seguro que ellos nunca podrán
tenerlo bien y fue entonces cuando el
rey replicó arregla esa es una gran idea
vamos a ver si pueden resolver el
problema de las papas fritas así que
resistir que ustedes les dicen cómo
podemos averiguar el promedio de cuántas
papas fritas necesitamos ordenar y para
esto necesitamos averiguar cuántas papas
fritas comer cada hombre en promedio y
cuántas papas fritas comer cada mujer
del reino en promedio y en eso
interrumpes al rey y le dices y qué pasa
con los niños a lo que replican
en este reino tenemos prohibidas las
papas fritas a los niños y bueno estos
por cuestiones de salud como debes
recordar en las últimas fiestas
tuvimos 500 adultos de los cuales en la
última fiesta eran 200 hombres mientras
que había 300 mujeres y en total
aquellas veces se comieron entre todos
1200 bolsas de papas fritas perfecto y
le preguntas y que pasó en la fiesta
anterior a esa y el rey te va a decir
aquella vez fueron muchos menos hombres
solo fueron 100 hombres así que fueron
100 hombres y 400 mujeres y en aquella
ocasión bajó el número de bolsas de
papas fritas en aquella ocasión se
consumieron solamente 1100 bolsas de
papas fritas pues vamos a resolverla y
lo primero que se me ocurren es que hay
que definir variables así que vamos a
definir variables y vamos a poner aquí
sea en mente igual a la cantidad o al
promedio de papas fritas que se consume
al número de papas fritas que come un
hombre o cada hombre en promedio
mientras que voy a decir que w va a ser
el número de papas fritas el número de
bolsas de papas fritas que consume cada
mujer en promedio cada mujer que asistió
a esta fiesta y bueno pues a
continuación lo que hay que hacer es
buscar las ecuaciones que estén
asociadas a la información ya los datos
que nos da el rey y nos dice en la
primera fiesta había 200 hombres y 300
mujeres en total se comieron 1200 bolsas
de papas fritas así que 200 por m porque
m es el número de bolsas de papas fritas
en promedio que comen cada uno de los
hombres siempre por ejemplo más de 10 10
veces se comería cada uno de los hombres
y entonces en total duran consumidos
2000 bolsas de papas fritas siempre por
ejemplo vale 33 por 200 son 600 y en
total de hombres habían consumido 600
bolsas de papas fritas y bueno es muy
parecido con las mujeres
300 por w 300 porque 300 fueron las
mujeres que fueron a esta fiesta por el
promedio de bolsas de papas fritas que
se comen cada una de las mujeres y si
sumamos estos dos 200 m más 300 w
tienen que ser igual a 1200 bolsas de
papas fritas es lo que me dice el
primero de nuestros datos y con la misma
lógica voy a sacar la segunda ecuación
que es el segundo de nuestros datos que
nos dan raid fueron 100 hombres y 400
mujeres a nuestra penúltima fiesta y se
consumieron 1100 bolsas de papas fritas
entonces 100 por m más 400 por w va a
ser igual a 1100 bolsas de papas fritas
estoy utilizando la misma lógica que
utilice en la ecuación pasada si yo me
fijo ahora que tengo 400 mujeres y si a
cada una de las mujeres la multiplicó
por el número promedio de bolsas de
papas fritas que se comió cada una de
las mujeres que fue esa fiesta me va a
dar el número de bolsas de papas fritas
que se comieron en total las mujeres y
si sumo estos dos entonces esto tiene
que ser igual al número de bolsas papas
fritas que se consumieron en esas
fiestas de 1100
lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
esto es muy parecido a lo que resolvimos
en el vídeo pasado sin embargo aquí hay
algo distinto en el vídeo pasado
teníamos 500 hombres en ambas ecuaciones
y por lo tanto se podían cancelar aquí
no tengo ninguno de mis coeficientes de
mis dos variables iguales por lo tanto
se me va a ocurrir a hacer otra pequeña
modificación para que pueda resolver
este sistema de ecuaciones por el mismo
método de la vez pasada lo que voy a
hacer es tomarme la ecuación número dos
y multiplicar la por menos dos pero la
voy a multiplicar toda completa tanto de
un lado de la ecuación como del otro
lado de la ecuación para no alterar la
ecuación iba a quedar menos 200m menos
800w es igual a menos 2.200 y si te das
cuenta el 200m que tengo aquí arriba en
la ecuación de amarillo y el menos 200 m
que me va a quedar de multiplicar la
segunda ecuación x menos 2 se pueden
cancelar lo que me va a dar pie otra vez
a una ecuación de solamente una variable
como tenían el vídeo pasado y bueno esto
lo puedo hacer porque tenemos una
ecuación
es una igualdad y esta igualdad cuando
yo lo modificó de un lado de la ecuación
mientras la siga modificando por lo
mismo del otro lado de la ecuación se va
a seguir manteniendo la igualdad prueba
tanto podemos hacerlo y entonces voy a
multiplicar esta ecuación por menos 2 me
queda menos 2 por 100 es menos 200 m
después menos 2 por 400 me queda menos
800 w y esto es igual a menos 2200
porque menos 2 por 1100 es lo mismo que
menos 2.200 estoy multiplicando por
menos 2 del lado izquierdo de esta
ecuación y también del lado derecho de
la ecuación para que se mantengan la
igualdad y ahora a continuación lo que
voy a hacer es poner la ecuación de
amarillo que tengo aquí arriba aquí
abajo para poder operar estos dos y que
tengo de la cuestión de amarillo me
queda 200 m más 300 w es igual a 1200
200 m 300 w es igual a 1200 y qué creés
date cuenta que ahora es menos 200 m y
el 200 m si lo sumo se cancelan se van
por lo tanto vamos a hacerlo
fíjate que aquí hay algo importante como
voy a sumar estas partes del lado
izquierdo de mis dos ecuaciones estoy
modificando mi igualdad
sin embargo cuando yo me doy cuenta que
200 m 300 w
lo que estoy sumando del lado izquierdo
de la ecuación es igual a 1200 y lo
pongo del lado derecho y después sumo
estas dos cantidades se sigue
manteniendo una igualdad que es justo lo
que quiero y ahora sí ya que tengo esto
bien definido vamos a hacer las
operaciones que tienen que ver estos se
van y me quedan menos 800 w más 300 w
esto es menos 500 w menos 500 w esto es
igual a 2200 negativo más 1200 y esto es
1000 mil negativo entonces tengo menos
500 w es igual a menos 1000 y date
cuenta que aquí ya tengo una ecuación
con una incógnita la cual le puedo
despejar si yo divido esto entre menos
500 puedo despejar a w y que me quedan w
es igual a quien menos 500 menos 500 se
van y me queda que menos 1000 entre
menos 500 es igual a 2
y por lo tanto ya tengo el valor de w w
es igual a 2 o dicho de otra manera el
número de bolsas de papas fritas que se
comen las mujeres en promedio es igual a
2 pero todavía no he acabado el problema
ya tengo el valor de w pero nos falta el
valor de m y de la misma manera que yo
hice en el vídeo pasado voy a despejar
algunas de las dos ecuaciones
utilizando que w vale 2 es decir
sustituyendo el valor de w igualados en
alguna de las dos ecuaciones voy a poder
obtener el valor de m y voy a utilizar
la ecuación de abajo que es la más
sencilla me queda que 100 en el más 400
por w pero wv2 entonces más 400 por 2
100 más 400 por 2 esto tiene que ser
igual a 1100 que es lo que me decía mi
ecuación de azul con la que empecé 100 m
más 400 w es igual a 1100 y vamos a
seguir operando 100 m más 800 esto es
igual a 1100 400 por 2 es igual a 800 y
si ahora paso restando 800 de ambos
lados de la ecuación que me va a quedar
del lado izquierdo me va a quedar
solamente 100 m porque estos dos se
cancelan si nm es igual a 1100 menos 800
esto es 300 y ahora ya tengo una
ecuación con solamente una incógnita que
en cuenta que quiero si divido todo
entre 100 me queda que m es igual a 3
300 entre 100 es lo mismo que 3 y si
entre 100 se van y por lo tanto ya tengo
también la cantidad de bolsas en
promedio que se come cada uno de los
hombres ya sé que w de 2 que me vale 3 y
por lo tanto ya tengo mis dos incógnitas
así que ya está resolvimos el problema
que nos puso el consejero al verla u2
vista el resultado usando la magia y los
poderes del álgebra así que otra vez
puedes quedar bien con el rey y decirle
la solución